Now that you've conducted
some user testing,
you probably have a nice list
of bugs that you need to fix.
So go ahead and squash them.
Then once you've squashed all
those bugs it's a good idea to do
another round of user testing, and
then you might find some more bugs and
then you'll squash those, and maybe
you'll have some more users test and
the cycle will repeat until
your app isn't crashing and
you're ready to either submit
it to the App Store, or,
if you're a nano degree student,
to submit it for grading.
So if you'd like to submit to
the App Store, we have instructions for
what you need to know,
what you need to prepare, and
what you can expect in
the next few reading notes.